Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications, and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful, and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get on to the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end.
你好，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家集体》这本书来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，这让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多反思。它也有助于让我以正确的视角看待事物，并提醒我，如果我今年没有考上博士，那也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于，每个人的旅程都是多么鼓舞人心。每天早上用这些故事作为我的动力，真是一种享受。我几乎不舍得读完它。
Recently, I watched the Netflix documentary Worst X ever, which tells the story of Wade Wilson. Like many people, I found myself wondering, how did people not see who he really was sooner? I think the answer is charisma. So let's take a look at why humans are seemingly so won over by charm. Why confidence, charisma and likeability can sometimes stop us from seeing what's right in front of us. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is in a work. Thank you for being here. This episode really came to me as an idea after I'd done the main episode of psychology actually with Dr. Emma Kavanaugh. In that we were discussing her book The Psychopath Effect and I said that I had recently watched some Netflix dramas which highlighted this exact thing pretty well. So let's use a little bit of a vignette thinking about Wade Wilson, the man
最近，我看了Netflix的纪录片《史上最差前任》，讲述了韦德·威尔逊的故事。和许多人一样，我当时就在想，为什么人们没有早点看清他的真面目？我认为答案是魅力。所以，让我们来看看为什么人类似乎如此容易被魅力所折服。为什么自信、魅力和讨人喜欢有时会阻止我们看清眼前的事实。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，这是《内在工作》。感谢您的收听。这一集的内容灵感确实来自于我与艾玛·卡瓦诺博士录制完《心理学实际上》的主集之后。在那一集中，我们讨论了她的书《精神病态效应》，我说我最近看了一些Netflix的剧集，它们很好地突出了这一点。所以，让我们用一个小片段来思考一下韦德·威尔逊，那个
portrayed in that Netflix drama to have a look at the key indicators where we perhaps should have been able to heed what we now know is like. traits of psychopathy. This is obviously just a caveat. Whilst I'm a clinical psychologist, I've never worked with Wade or with anyone known to him or the people involved in the case. Instead, we are using what was portrayed in the documentary and the literature for psychopathy. So the first person we're introduced to in the Netflix documentary is Kelly Matthews, who met Wade on online dating. And having chatted to Emma, having read the book, think it's likely that Wade was using what Kelly said about herself online, about her hopes,
在那部Netflix剧中被刻画的人物，来看看我们本应该能够注意到的一些关键指标，也就是我们现在所知的精神病态特征。这显然只是一个免责声明。虽然我是一名临床心理学家，但我从未与韦德或任何认识他的人或案件相关人员共事过。相反，我们使用的是纪录片中描绘的内容以及关于精神病态的文献。因此，我们在Netflix纪录片中见到的第一个人是凯利·马修斯，她是在网上约会时认识韦德的。在与艾玛交谈并读过那本书后，我认为韦德很可能利用了凯利在网上对自己、对她的希望、
her dreams, the things that she wanted to achieve in life to make sure that all of the interactions he was having with her, you know, before they even got to the stage of meeting, were feeling like she was potentially meeting her soulmate. And so, you know, the potential for love bombing starts early, especially, you know, perhaps when he turns up and she thinks, oh actually he is, you know, really good looking. He's got that smile. And he's got those dimples. If you look at him online, he's got those dimples. And I do think that people with dimples can get away with a lot more because they look kind of quite cheeky. I wonder whether he was very good at doing that type of smile that reaches the eyes. So in order to have a dimple, maybe, you know,
她的梦想以及她想在生活中实现的目标所说的话，以确保他在与她见面之前的所有互动中，都让她觉得她可能遇到了灵魂伴侣。所以，你知道，爱情轰炸的可能性很早就开始了，尤其是当他出现时，她心想，哦，实际上他真的很帅。他有那种微笑。他还有酒窝。如果你在网上看他，他有酒窝。我确实认为有酒窝的人可以逃脱更多的惩罚，因为他们看起来很调皮。我不知道他是否非常擅长那种能触及眼睛的微笑。所以为了有酒窝，也许，你知道，
psychologically, we think that is a true and genuine smile, whereas some of the smile. of that might have been, you know, masking or acting or part of the kind of love bombing of getting Kelly to feel like they were into something special. And other than the first meeting, the first thing that got my spidey senses tingling, obviously knowing that I was watching a true crime documentary. So that is a little bit different to be coming to as a position compared to the people who were part of this story. But the first thing that really got my spidey senses tingling, was, you know, just how quickly this moved and how she felt like she had met her soulmate and how before too long he was moving in with her, living with her.
从心理学上讲，我们认为那是真实而真诚的微笑，而其中一些微笑可能只是掩饰、表演，或者是爱情轰炸的一部分，让凯利觉得他们正在经历一段特别的感情。除了第一次见面，让我产生警觉的第一件事，显然是因为我知道我正在看一部真实犯罪纪录片。所以这与故事中的当事人所处的立场有点不同。但真正让我产生警觉的第一件事是，你知道，这段关系发展得太快了，她觉得她遇到了灵魂伴侣，而且没过多久他就搬进来和她一起住了。
And that played out again later in the episode as he then moved in with other women quickly as well. And so, you know, I think it's that sense of, oh, well, he must really like me because he wants to live with me and we can get distracted, um, especially. I loved it when Emma said, actually, when we're with these people who are very strong in charisma, actually shuts down a part of our brain that leads us to question any other narrative than that which the highly charismatic leader person has. And so if they seem like they're very on board with this, then it can be actually inhibiting our ability to see the wood for the trees. So yes, perhaps, you know, Kelly might have realised this is quite quick,
这一点在这一集的后面再次上演，因为他很快也搬去和其他女性住在一起。所以，你知道，我认为这是一种“哦，他一定很喜欢我，因为他想和我住在一起”的感觉，我们可能会分心，尤其是。我很高兴艾玛说，实际上，当我们和这些非常有魅力的人在一起时，它实际上关闭了我们大脑中导致我们质疑除了那个极具魅力的人所说的叙述之外的任何其他叙述的部分。所以，如果他们看起来非常赞同这一点，那么这实际上可能会抑制我们透过现象看本质的能力。所以是的，也许，你知道，凯利可能意识到这太快了，
but because it all feels so good, and I think because we do have those Hollywood and fairy tale stories of things moving very quickly when we meet the right people, you begin to tell yourself, well, this must just be, you know, my Prince Charming. And as we know, that is absolutely not what happened. The other thing that I'm really, really saw that I didn't like, and that initially I thought was a bit of a police play, was when, as viewers, we saw the police interview with Wade, who I think she thought was called Stephen at the time as well. And I thought the police was being, and I thought it was a strategy of kind of getting alongside the person that was accused of the crime, to then make them say
但因为这一切感觉太好了，而且我认为因为我们确实有那些好莱坞和童话故事，讲述当我们遇到对的人时事情发展得非常快，你开始告诉自己，好吧，这一定就是我的白马王子。正如我们所知，事实绝对不是这样。我看到的另一件我非常非常不喜欢的事情，起初我认为这是一种警察策略，那就是当作为观众，我们看到警察采访韦德时，我想当时她以为他叫斯蒂芬。我以为警察是在采取一种策略，即与被指控犯罪的人站在一起，然后让他们说出
something which could then be used in evidence against them, that didn't seem to be the case. He did seem quite pally, quite chummy, and I understand was suspended for a couple of weeks after that investigation happened as well. But that really did seem to be. That is as good as the investigation got. And what looked a bit like a kind of pally pally, camaraderie type interview didn't ever go any deeper than that, and no charges were brought, as I understand it, as I remember it. And that's kind of horrifying. And I think that Kelly has rightly since tried to make sure that lessons are learned from that experience. And that absolutely made me think about the UK law called Claire's Law,
一些可以作为反对他们的证据的话，但事实似乎并非如此。他看起来确实很友好，很亲切，据我所知，在那次调查之后，他也确实被停职了几周。但这似乎就是调查的全部了。看起来像是一种亲密友好的采访，并没有深入下去，据我所知，据我记忆所及，也没有提出任何指控。这真是太可怕了。我认为凯利此后理所当然地试图确保从那次经历中吸取教训。这绝对让我想到了英国的一项法律，叫做“克莱尔法”，
which allows partners or new partners to be able to actually actually. or request information about whether someone has a domestic violence history. I do wonder, obviously, if she'd known that his real name was Wade, whether had she been able to do that, whether there might have been more information that she could have access to allow her to make an informed choice. But of course, this charisma is all feeling like it's really going well and him bringing down her kind of defences and her ability to think
它允许伴侣或新伴侣能够实际请求了解某人是否有家庭暴力史的信息。我确实在想，如果她当时知道他的真名是韦德，如果她能够做到这一点，是否会有更多信息供她获取，让她能够做出明智的选择。但当然，这种魅力让人感觉一切都很顺利，他消除了她的防御心理和她思考的能力，
that this is anything other than a really great relationship. always meant that he was more likely to get what he wanted. And ultimately it's a harrowing, harrowing story. Have you watched the Netflix drama Worst X Ever? What did you think? I would love your thoughts. Have you been disarmed by someone that's charismatic? Even the word charismatic for me, since finishing this book, well, it's changed. I think whenever I hear someone being described as charismatic in future, it's going to make me stop and think. If you haven't already watched the episode I did on coercive and controlling behaviour, I think you'll find it really, really interesting. Thank you for being here. Thanks for being a fan of Inner Work. The next episode
认为这不仅仅是一段非常棒的关系，这意味着他更有可能得到他想要的。归根结底，这是一个令人痛苦、令人痛苦的故事。你看过Netflix的剧集《史上最差前任》吗？你觉得怎么样？我很想听听你的想法。你有没有被有魅力的人解除过武装？对我来说，自从读完这本书后，甚至“有魅力”这个词的含义都变了。我想将来每当我听到有人被描述为有魅力时，我都会停下来思考一下。如果你还没有看过我做的关于强制和控制行为的那一集，我想你会发现它非常非常有趣。感谢您的收听。感谢您成为《内在工作》的粉丝。下一集
will be available wherever you get your podcasts and on YouTube from 8pm UK time, with of course the episodes of psychology actually coming out on Saturdays and Mondays. Thank you for being part of my world. Take care of yourself. Be kind. Watch out for that charisma. I'll see you soon. Bye. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're
将在您获取播客的任何地方以及YouTube上于英国时间晚上8点发布，当然《心理学实际上》的剧集会在周六和周一发布。感谢您成为我世界的一部分。照顾好自己。保持善良。小心那种魅力。我们很快再见。再见。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到目标的不同途径之多让我感到惊讶，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你
feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you star. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。